At the end last time we asked the question whether molecular mechanics programs
are useful,
and the answer is yes.
In fact,
there really nowadays indispensable for evaluating the energy of molecules and
their shapes.
But are they true?
Are they really fundamentally correct?
The same way we believe quantum mechanics to be fundamentally correct?
And the answer to that is certainly no.
We already saw how there they depend on so many arbitrary parameters that are
just adjusted to try to fit data from some molecules.
And then there's the hope that they'll fit other molecules and sometimes they do
and sometimes they don't.
They usually do pretty well,
but there can be special cases that differ for some reason and it's hard to
predict those ahead of time.
So one has to look at them with a certain grain of salt.
Okay.
Uh,
a good example of,
of where they're demonstrably incorrect is in the question of Vander walls
radii.
I,
for example,
the contact between two bromine atoms that are not bonded to one another.
So we're going to make a plot showing the bromine attached to carbon.
And we're going to do this in the same spirit that done,
it's in his grew,
uh,
looked at,
means attacking carbon.
We're going to look at many,
many crystal structures and we're going to have,
we're going to rotate the various structures so that they have a CBR bond that
lines up right there.
And then we're going to see how far it is to the nearest neighboring bromine
from some other molecule.
Okay.
And now what would we expect?
Well,
there's a certain Vander walls,
radius for bromine.
So the next neighbor should have it's bromine in contact with that one.
So we should go that radius again to get to a neighbor.
And there should be various directions of course,
where the neighbor could be,
but always at that same distance if they are in contact with one another.
Okay?
So there should be,
uh,
an arc of a circle like that.
So if we,
if we make the,
if we rotate these various crystal structures that have been determined,
so the sea and Vr lineup there and the other br lies in the plane,
the neighboring br from another molecule,
then the closest they should get is along that dashed red line.
Now of course,
there could be others that are further away that aren't in contact,
and in fact there could be some that are a little bit closer.
You'd really expect something to be a little bit closer because there's Vander
walls attraction out to infinite distance at least to great,
to substantial distance much further than where they are actually in contact.
They're attracting one another.
So these,
these,
this bromine is part of a molecule that has many atoms in it and the other
bromine is part of a molecule that has many Adams and all these other atoms are
attracting one another,
pulling toward one another.
Now of course that would just collapse except for the fact that the ones,
the closest ones run into one another.
But that means that they should get slightly closer than just precise contact
because they're being pushed together by all the other bollock Adam's in those
molecules.
So we would expect neighbors the be slightly closer.
Some of the neighbors at least to be slightly closer than this dander,
walls,
radius,
they're double the Vander walls,
whatever the van der walls radius means.
All right?
The question is where you get that.
But at any rate,
we could make that,
you can look up in a book and see what they say.
The van der waals radius of bromine is,
and make a plot like this,
and then you'll put points on it for all the different crystal structures of
where neighboring bromines are and they look like this.
I'll say,
here's what I just said,
the balance,
attractive and repulsive forces between neighbors.
The closest Adam's must be a little bit too close,
okay?
And here's what you see.
And indeed,
some of the atoms in some of the cases are a little bit too close.
And of course many are further because other atoms are running into one another
of these two molecules.
Okay.
Well,
what do you notice in particular that you find particularly,
uh,
curious about this plot?
Anything,
John,
you
can't hear very well.
It's not circular.
It's in the lips,
right?
There are many more inside the red dashed line at the top,
then out to the side.
So what do you infer from that?
About the shape of the bromine atom?
Correct?
It's not spherical.
Right.
Okay.
So the bromine,
Adam seem not to be spherical,
right?
But every molecular mechanics program calculates Vander walls interactions
between Adams as if they are spherical at the interaction depends only on the
distance,
not on the direction,
right?
So clearly molecular mechanics programs are not perfect,
But still they're pretty good and you couldn't get interesting information at
them.
Plus from them.
Plus they can tell you something about why something might be the way it is,
right?
Tortional energy and things like that.
Okay.
And in fact,
if you're trying to deal with a big molecule,
it's hopeless to do quantum mechanics on it.
So here's a angia stat,
which is an anticancer drug.
And this is the large,
at least as of a couple of years ago,
I suspect it's still the case.
This is the largest molecule whose shape has been optimized by quantum
mechanics,
right,
and not a really high level of quantum mechanics.
It was,
here's a description of it from Mike Frisch from Gaussian incorporated in 2003
he said we optimize kringle one,
which is this thing,
I don't know why you call it kringle one with the am one method,
which is a very low level of quantum mechanics using Gaussian oh three
plasminogen kringle one contains 1200 atoms,
which are made up of 642 non hydrogen atoms and 578 hydrogen atoms.
The job takes about 650 optimization steps starting from the molecular mechanics
geometry.
So first they use molecular mechanics to get the approximate structure.
And then they started adjusting that with quantum mechanics step by step until
after 650 steps,
they got to a minimum of energy.
And that's this energy.
But obviously this is not an everyday occurrence to do something like this.
So if you're dealing with a big biological molecule,
you have to use molecular mechanics,
right?
But you know that fundamentally it's not right.
It may get a lot of things right,
but don't believe that it came down from Sinai on the tablets,
right?
Yes.
Lucas,
they,
uh,
I don't know.
We could ask him sometime.
He's around here from time to time.
I haven't set it up.
They come in.
Okay.
So quantum mechanics is pretty close as we believe to the truth.
Molecular mechanics isn't close to the truth.
For practical purposes,
it's indispensable.
Now we wonder whether the standard structural model of molecules that we have is
realistic and it's geometric detail things about bonds,
bond lengths,
bond angles and so on.
And how are we going to know whether it is,
we're going to use x ray de fraction to see just how regular bond distances are.
Okay.
Now we're helped in this by what's called the Cambridge structural database and
Cambridge in England.
There's this a building where people sit and collect ex-ray structure data from
all over the world and,
and uh,
make it a computer searchable and so on.
So that you can look at many,
many structures and you see that many structures are available.
This is how many structures there are as of any particular year in the Cambridge
structural database.
And you see it's up to about a half a million x structures have been determined
and put in the Cambridge database.
As of now,
you can click on there and go to the website to see it if you want.
It's interesting.
Okay.
And they predict that there'll be half a million by 2010
okay.
Now how many atoms are there,
and this is how many structures,
how many atoms are there?
How many bonds in each structure?
Well,
as time goes on,
as Xray is able to do more and more complicated molecules.
So that at the beginning there were only about an average of 27 Adam's in a
structure,
but by 1982 there were 44 and by 1990 there were 54 and by after 2002 or
something like that,
there were 73 so the molecules are getting bigger and bigger.
And as of now,
as at least as of last January,
the last issue of the database,
there were 30 million,
30 and a half million Adam positions,
x,
Y,
z coordinates available,
right?
And of course there are many more bonds than there are atoms because most atoms
for several bonds.
So there are greater than 40 million bond distances available.
Now the question is how regular are they?
Do Carbon carbon bond distances tend to be the same?
Well,
in 1987,
when the Cambridge data database was much smaller than it is now,
it was already large enough to do pretty good statistics on this thing.
And here's a paper published in that year that you could look at if you want to,
uh,
by people from the,
the,
uh,
crystal graphic data center in Cambridge that talked about this subject.
Now here's a table that shows how many different kinds of bonds they divided the
experimental data into.
So that within any given type,
the bonds would all be about the same length,
right?
It's not surprising that different types of bonds have different lengths,
but if you subdivide that like double bonds and single bonds will be different
lengths,
right?
So those would be at least two types.
But notice how many types they used.
So for example,
there are 119 different types of carbon oxygen bonds that they did statistics
on,
not bonds,
but types of bonds.
Okay.
Now here,
here are those 119 different types.
They're 60 types that are made up of an sp three carbon bonded to an o of type
two and there are 17 types of bonds,
which have s p squared carbon bonded to that type of,
of carbon.
Oh two means the oxygen is bonded to two different atoms.
Oh one it's bonded to just want Adam,
right?
There are four types where that's an aromatic carbon that's bonded to a dive Ala
Doxygen,
and they're 38 we're an SP squared car,
but as bonded to an oxygen that makes bonds to only one carbon.
That is a CEO double bond.
So there are 38 different types of CEO double bonds,
okay.
Or in the case of CNN,
they're 97 different types of CN bonds in this,
in their tabulation.
And for carbon,
there are 175 different types of carbon carbon bonds.
And notice that there are 27 different types of carbon carbon bonds where both
the carbons are p cubed hybridized,
right?
So they're dividing this and the lots and lots of different categories in order
to get regularity within each category.
Now let's,
uh,
let's look here at,
at uh,
the one that those 27 different kinds of bonds that are carbon s p cubed to
carbon SB cubed.
Okay?
So for each,
for each type is given the mean and the median two kinds of average of the bod
distance.
What the standard deviation is,
how,
how many,
uh,
what the distance is that splits off the,
the,
the shortest one,
fourth and the longest.
One fourth.
And then how many different examples there were to do this,
this,
uh,
the,
to,
to make this statistics on,
okay,
so now in this table,
see,
with a pound sign means any sp three carbon.
So at the top there we see a ch a ch three bonded to ch two so that's the bond
distance we're interested in methyl to ch two but that ch two has some other sp
three carbon on it,
right?
So that's one type of bond.
And you notice the mean distance is 1.513 and if it's,
if there are two sp three carbons on the second carbon,
then it's 1.5 to four average.
And if there are three of them,
it's 1.53 for now.
Notice the standard deviation is about 1% of the bond distance.
So within that class,
they're all within about plus or minus 1% right?
So a very small deviations.
So they,
they wanted to get them,
they wanted to make the classes restricted enough that you'd have a predictable
bond distance,
right?
Within 1% okay?
Notice that crowding seems to stretch the bond.
As you put more carbons on that second carbon,
which is bonded to methyl,
the bond to methyl gets longer and longer,
longer by a little less than 1%.
As you put more crowding on the second carbon,
here's a graph of it,
right?
Of that,
uh,
the standard deviation and the mean,
right?
So you'll see it gets as you go from one are to two hours to three hours on the
second carbon,
the bond gets a little longer and a little longer,
although they can overlap.
Okay?
Now,
then we go down to here where both carbons are substituted.
So the first carbon has,
uh,
two or three carbons on it and the second car,
but also has two or three carbons on it.
And now you see there's still more crowding.
It gets,
they get longer and longer.
And in fact,
when you have three other carbons on each of the carbons,
who's bond you're interested in,
then those others repel one another by van der walls.
Repulsion.
And it gets actually pretty long,
right?
It gets almost 10% L'Oreal 7% longer or something like that.
So anyhow,
you can get these kinds of regularities based on the,
the,
uh,
statistics and if you want to just an overall average carbon carbon bond
distance,
uh,
it's about 1.53 angst rooms,
okay.
However,
if you have psycholo propane or cycle of butane,
then the bonds are in the case of cycle of wrote propane,
unusually short 1.51 and in the case of cycle of butane unusually long,
1.55.
Okay.
Now if you have sp three sp two as a carbon carbon bond rather than sp three sp
three,
then what would you expect?
Would you expect to shorter bond or a longer bond?
If one of them is sp squared,
just guess
sp squared means you'll get better overlap,
stronger bond,
probably a shorter bond.
This,
a little review for you here.
Okay.
And indeed,
1.5 is the average.
So there,
there are hundreds and hundreds of these as you can see in this,
in this particular paper.
But if you want just order of magnitude things,
actually it's better than an order of magnitude.
But for carbon,
carbon single bonds,
it's about 1.53 ons.
Drums for double bonds,
1.32 for triple bonds,
1.18 and for aromatic bonds they within a benzene ring,
these are one and a half bonds.
So not surprisingly they come between single and double.
Okay.
Notice there are a little closer to double than they are to single
1.3820000000000001 1.32 as opposed to 1.38 versus 1.53 does it surprise you that
they're a little closer to double than single
notice?
Even if they were single bonds but between carbons that were part of aromatic
rings,
it would be s p squared,
s p squared,
carbon carbon bonds and we've already seen that those would be unusually short.
Right?
So you don't expect it to be one and a half.
The average between a normal single in a normal double if you think about it
with a little more sophistication.
Okay.
And then as we see here,
a single,
if it's sp three sp squared is 1.5 in a single.
If it's sp squared,
sp squared is 1.46 so the 1.38 is closer to being halfway between 1.46 and 1.32
than it is between 1.53 and 1.32.
So depending on how accurate your model needs to be,
you can get pretty good guesses based on values you advised in the table.
Now you
can see some interesting,
uh,
departures from regularity in a,
here,
I'll show it in carbon to Matt in aromatic carbon to nitrogen bonds.
So there's a,
an anilin derivative.
Anaplan is Amino benzene.
Okay,
so there's that red bond is the bond we're talking about and there's the
distribution,
a histogram of distances.
What's funny about the Histogram,
Dana?
There's a hole in the middle,
right?
It's by modal,
So it looks like there are two different kinds of bonds between nitrogen and
aromatic carbon.
Now let's split them out.
The ones that are in one and the ones that are in the other and see how,
why they have this difference.
It turns out that if you do once where the nitrogen and the benzene are coke
planer as shown above,
then you have one nice histogram.
And if the nitrogen is pyramidal rather than being a planer,
then it's another histogram.
So it depends on whether the nitrogen is playing or or pyramidal.
But when the nitrogen is plainer,
it's Cope Planar with the benzene and for good reason,
it's so that the unshared pair on the nitrogen can be localized into vacant
orbitals Pi orbitals of the benzene ring.
So that makes this carbon to nitrogen bond a little bit,
double bond like,
and shortens it.
Whereas if the nitrogen is twisted compared to the benzene,
then there's no reason for it to be flat,
to have a p orbital that will overlap with the,
with the benzine or bundles.
So it becomes pyramidal.
But more importantly,
there's no double bond character anymore to the carbon nitrogen bond.
So the bonds are longer than the ones that are partial double bonds.
So that's why it's by modal.
So you'll learn something from these,
uh,
statistical analysis.
You have poor Pi overlapped when the nitrogen carbon bond is twisted.
Now,
how complex must've bottled B in order to predict useful structures.
So from the point of view of the Cambridge,
uh,
compilers,
they wanted to get standard deviations in bond distance of about 1% as you saw
from the table.
And in order to do this,
as you saw,
they needed a 175 different kinds of cc bonds
differing in these various ways as we've illustrated and 97 different types of
CN and 119 different types of CEO bonds and 682 different kinds of bonds all
together in their tape in there tabulation.
Okay,
now we have,
uh,
ambitious goals.
We want to understand all stuff chemicals.
That is okay.
Uh,
we wonder how things behave,
their properties and their chemical transformations as well.
Right?
And the key to doing this,
the trick we're going to use is to understand the basis of structure,
how the atoms are arranged and energy.
And we want to do this in terms of bonds.
You could do it entirely without bonds.
Just use quantum mechanics to minimize energies of,
of atoms,
of arrangements,
and calculate those energies.
And you'd have that same information,
structured energy,
but you wouldn't understand anything.
You couldn't predict anything in your head.
With bonds,
you have a tool that will allow you to predict things.
Okay?
So let's just see how well bonds do.
Obviously they're going to be corrections having to do with confirmation and
strain as we've been talking about.
But is there an underlying energy for a given composition or a given
constitution,
a given set of bonds?
Can you predict energy as well as structure?
In other words,
how standard our bond energies,
if we're going to do our understanding in terms of bonds,
can you add up energies for all the bonds and get the overall energy for the
molecule knowing of course,
that they're going to be corrections for strain and so on?
Okay.
So,
uh,
this started in 1868 already in the very first issue.
The second paper of the first issue of the German,
uh,
chemical journal came Cheveria data,
which was the journal of the Chemical Society of Berlin.
The second paper ever in that journal was on the regularity and calculation of
heat,
of combustion,
of organic compounds.
So Herrmann was interested in this because he was a physiologist and he wanted
to know how much,
uh,
energy you get out of the food you burn up in your body,
right?
So could you predict on the basis of what substances you eat,
how much energy could be available?
Okay,
so for physiology led him to study this and there was another paper very shortly
after that in the same journal by Oppenheim on the relationship of heat of
combustion with the constitution of substance,
right?
So could you look at the constitution?
He didn't mean it yet.
Constitution notices 1868 still pretty early days.
He didn't mean constitution to mean nature and sequence of bonds,
he just mean meant what was in there.
Okay.
So how did they try to do this?
Could we do it the way they did it?
Uh,
by predicting the heat of combustion,
how much hate you get out of burning a thing?
Say just by how much carbon and hydrogen,
we know you can burn carbon coal and get a certain amount of heat out.
We know you can burn hydrogen gas and getting a certain amount of heat out.
Could you take a substance,
know how much carbon and how much hydrogen is in it and predict how much heat
you'll get out of burning it.
Right.
It would be great if that were true.
Okay,
so let's see how well it works.
So you,
you're going to compare to graphite.
That's a carbon and hydrogen,
right?
So we'd have a certain number of atoms per mole and uh,
and,
and then we know how,
what the heat of combustion is for per mole,
you get 94 kilocalories out of burning a mole of graphite,
mole of carbon and graphite.
You get a 57.8 out of burning hydrogen.
Okay.
That's per,
uh,
Gotcha.
I'd love to see,
I think that's per Adam not per molecule.
We'll see.
Yeah,
no,
it's per h two.
Okay.
So it's 94.05 per carbon and 57.8 per age too.
Now you take some other substance like ethene c two h four right?
So you should get two times 94.05 for the carbon and two times 57.8 because it's
57.8 for every two hydrogens.
You got four hydrogens.
So two times that.
So you should get 303.7 out of burning a mole of ethene.
Right?
In fact,
you get 316 right?
Which isn't bad.
It's a,
it's a error of 12 kilocalories per mole,
but that's only 4% so you're pretty close already in predicting that now.
So we can be optimistic,
but let's try something else.
Notice we can even understand why you get a little more heat out than you
expected because one of the bonds in c two h four is not such a strong bond,
right?
The second bond to the double bond is so strong.
So you,
so you expect the starting material not to be as stable as it might've been.
It's a little higher in energy than it would've been if that second bond was
really good.
So when you burn it,
you get more heat out because there was more in it to begin with,
right?
It was less stable to begin with.
So we can understand that.
Now let's try to extend it to other things.
How about cyclohexane?
There we have six carbons and 12 hydrogens.
You'd predict 911 it turns out to be 881 it's off by 29 but that's only a 3%
error,
right?
Not Bad.
We're doing well.
Now,
how about cyclohexane?
All right.
There again,
it has,
since it has the same amount,
you don't expect to get anything out of oxygen because it's already,
you can know the opposite eyes.
Oxygen,
right?
In birding,
it's only the carbon and hydrogen that you oxidize.
So you predict exactly the same 911 it's the same amount of hydrogen and carbon.
Uh,
but you only get out 842 instead of 880 so now you're off by 68 kilocalories per
mole or 8% and if you take sugar,
which is again c six h 12 but oh six now,
now you get out only 670 you're off by 240 so you're making a 36% error.
Now it's getting pretty bad.
Right?
Does that surprise you
that when there's oxygen in the molecule,
you get less out by burning,
less heat out,
by burning,
when there's already oxygen there?
What is burning?
What do you do?
You're oxidizing.
If these are already partly oxidized,
if they have oxygen in them.
So you've already gone partway,
you don't expect to get so much out anymore.
Right.
Okay.
So that,
that,
that makes sense.
They're partially pre oxidized.
So you make bigger,
you make errors in this.
So for fuel purposes,
for physiology,
this isn't so bad,
especially you could include some kind of correction for every oxygen that's
already there,
part way to the product then.
Then you'd get numbers that you know within a five maybe 10% are going to be
right,
so you actually could add up the just from the composition,
add up what atoms are there and predict how much heat you could get out by
burning right now,
but might you need a more complex model if what your goal is is to predict
chemically useful energies rather than just ones that say how much energy you're
going to get by burning your chocolate bar or whatever.
Okay.
For physiology purposes,
you might be content with plus or minus 5% but for predicting the equilibrium
constant between Cyclo,
hexane and cyclohexene all suppose there were some reaction oxidation reaction
where you,
where you can convert one to the other and you're all going to be off by a 1%
say which would be nine kilocalories per mole,
so you're off by 1% how off would you be in the equilibrium?
Constant.
How big a factor and equilibrium would nine kilocalories B,
do you remember how to do that?
How do you go from energy to equilibrium?
Constant.
I'm going to keep it boring in on this until you remember it.
Cause it's certainly going to be on the exam gathered.
You do the three quarters tended the three fourths of that.
Okay,
so three fourths of nine is about seven,
right?
So how by what factor would you be off and predicted an equilibrium constant if
you were off by nine kilocalories per mole,
the name is
10 to the seventh right?
Is that good enough to be off by 10 million fold?
Not very good.
Right?
So you're off by 10 to the seventh.
So a useful model clearly has to go to get better numbers than you can get just
from the composition,
just from what atoms are there.
You're going to have to consider bonds.
And that's what I said we were going to do to see how good it can be if you just
have certain energies for certain bonds.
So we need to go to constitution.
So now what?
We're going to talk about energy,
there's going to be a big,
a really fundamental question.
So here's cyclohexane.
It has a certain energy.
What number should I put on it?
Should I say it's 1328 562 million,
right?
The question is one of our fundamental questions.
What's that compared to what,
what are we going to call zero?
Okay.
Now,
for practical purposes of doing an experiment,
there's a very good reference and it's the one we've just been using without
saying.
So which is CO2 and h two o the same amount of carbon and CO2,
the same amount of hydrogen and h two o right?
Why is that a convenient a reference point to take from an experimental point of
view,
Lucas.
Ah,
so all you have to have to do is burn it.
See how much heat you get out and you know,
the energy relevant relative to see co two and h two o.
So that's called the heat of combustion and it turns out to be 881.6
kilocalories per mole for cyclohexane.
We were just talking about that.
Okay.
Now,
so it's easily measured.
That's a good comparison.
But if I hadn't told you that we wanted an experimental comparison that we
wanted sort of a uh,
you know,
uh,
simple to think about comparison,
maybe if you couldn't even measure,
what might you think of as a point of comparison?
If you're going to talk about,
we've got a whole bunch of different compounds,
we don't know how stable is compared to what,
what are we going to use as the,
what
one?
It could be unbounded atoms.
That would be a really good one because then when we start with atoms,
we put them together and make bonds.
And if there's a certain energy for each bond,
then we would be comparing our molecule or our model of the molecule with all
these bonds to the atoms.
That'd be a very good one.
But that's going to be a very hard with the deal with experimentally,
right to go to Adam's,
there's another thing that you could actually have in a bottle that might make
sense to compare it to and that would be the elements in their standard state.
So graphite,
how stable is it compared to graphite being the carbon and h two gas being the
hydrogen,
right?
So that if you're comparing to the elements in their standard states,
that difference,
notice that cyclohexene or cyclohexane is just slightly more stable than the
elements bonded to one another.
Right?
And that's called the heat of formation.
That's just the definition.
That's what the heat of formation is.
It's the energy compared to the elements in their standard state.
Okay.
Now,
but how could you measure that experimentally?
How would you get heat of formation?
You know,
the energy of cyclohexane relative to see co two and h two o by doing
combustion.
How would you know it relative to graphite and hydrogen?
You can't mix hydrogen and graphite and have it suddenly magically become
cyclohexane invasion.
The heat involved in that transformation.
But how could you get it?
Do you see?
There's a neat trick to use.
Ah,
you could burn the graphite and the hydrogen,
see how much he,
they get off and then take the difference.
Right?
So that's what you do.
You,
you burn that and get 911.1 and the difference.
Then 29.5 is the heat of formation of cyclohexane from the elements well done.
Okay.
But Andrew says it would be great for purposes of our Oh and in fact,
these heats of formation are available in tables for lots and lots of compounds.
And this brings up a question.
This a payable is taken and there are several others,
spheres for alkanes,
Cyclo,
alkanes,
alkanes aromatic hydrocarbons and everything's,
you can look these up,
even find them on the web to all these uh,
uh,
heats of formation.
So it's how stable the particular substances and it's not just,
uh,
molecules.
Notice they also have Adam's and radicals,
inorganic compounds,
cad ions,
and an ions,
all of them relative to the elements.
So you can find tables like this.
These particular tables I took from a book by Stripe,
wiser Hedgecock and Casar,
which we've often used as a textbook in the course.
I think it might be out of print.
Now they've met the publisher based,
still have some copies.
But would you like to have a textbook for second semester so we don't have to
continue with the wiki stuff now,
so if we're going to do that,
we have to make the decision.
Are we going to get us a slick new book that has a lot of nice color pictures in
it and so on and the very latest thing?
Or are we going to get something like stripe wiser and Hedgecock,
which I think is a wonderful book,
but you're going to have to find second hand copies or maybe the publishers
still has a few words on these new books.
They charge an absolute arm and a leg for the visit.
You probably have found out,
so I want to do it however you want to do it.
Actually,
why don't you think about it a little bit.
I like this book,
but there are plenty of other books that are just fine for our purposes and we
won't be 100% in the book.
You won't be surprised to hear,
but there'll,
there'll be a lot of stuff that could be useful in having a textbook genu
okay.
Somebody in instruction,
clarity stuff,
how to make a lot of difference.
In fact,
we could probably get one of these,
you know,
uh,
outlines of organic chemistry,
you know,
the little paperback books and so on that we'd probably have the stuff we
wanted,
but then you probably couldn't hold your head up against your roommates and so
on if you have a little dinky book like that.
Uh,
so when,
when I took organic chemistry,
uh,
the,
the professor was professor fees or who wrote lots and lots of textbooks and he
had just written one for nurses for a one semester course.
So we took two semesters and use the book that was about that thick.
It was,
oh,
a do embarrassed.
I didn't know enough to be embarrassed at that time and it was a good book.
I don't have that anymore.
I don't,
somebody borrowed it from me then give it back and they said the book.
But uh,
anyhow,
we can talk about this a little more than next time,
but thank,
thank over.
Whether you want to fork out for a shiny new book or would rather have a book,
which I think is equal in quality,
maybe better even that you'd have to go buy a second hand copies or something,
but it'd save you some money.
So think about it.
We'll talk about it next time.
Okay.
And yeah,
that's where I got this table.
Uh,
now let's look at the heat of formation from this book of Cyclo Alkanes.
And so cyclo alkanes are ch two groups in a ring,
right?
Six Ch,
two groups of Cyclohexane,
two ch two groups is cyclo ethnic cyclo ethane or ethylene,
right?
So now here's the heat of formation there.
There,
uh,
how big the ring is,
two carbons,
three carbons,
four carbons and so on.
And what the heat of formation is.
Now let's try to make sense out of this.
We could look at the heat of formation divided by how many carbon or ch two
units there are in there.
It could be,
they'd all be the same.
That would be the simplest thing.
If all we had to do is take how many ch two groups there were there and that up
and we would get what the,
uh,
what the stability is and it's,
it's uh,
it's,
uh,
they're not too bad,
but again,
compared to what?
Right.
So you're going to be the biggest error is six that I see there.
And the more typical error is about four say or something like that.
So for that would be if you are off by four kilocalories per mole.
Ah,
but it's per ch two group.
Uh,
so it gets worse,
right?
If you have a lot of cs two groups,
there's a lot of energy.
So it's,
if we're only one ch two group,
you'd be off only by a factor of a thousand.
If you had that kind of error.
Okay.
Uh,
oh,
wait a second.
This isn't an error.
This is just what it is per per group.
Right.
So it's uh,
well let's go one step further here.
The minimum is 4.9.
That's for cyclohexane our old favorite,
which isn't a strange,
remember,
at least not very strained.
This chair cyclohexane okay.
So let's suppose that that's the standard and everything else is a little bit
higher in energy,
more positive because there's some kind of strain there.
Okay.
How big is that strain?
Well,
let's compare what it would be.
So we'll call that four.
You'd get,
we'll say you'll get 4.9 reduced compared to the elements if you're have
unstrained brain and now we're going to look at the others and see how strained
they are.
Now notice down at the bottom here,
1314,
50 and 60 and he's big rings have almost exactly the same energy.
So they're not strained,
right?
We would get a very good prediction of what their heat of formation is.
If we just multiply,
uh,
from the value we got from cyclohexane.
But the others here are a little bit off.
So of streamless theory is n times minus 4.9 predicts our heat.
So you'll see that we have a strain energy,
which is the experiment that column shown versus theory that at the end times
4.9 and here,
here are the strain energy.
We see,
nope,
almost no strain energy down at the bottom with just a few kilocalories per
mole.
That's not going to hurt us very much.
But up at the top we have strained.
The first one is bad ethylene.
We know because of the double bond is so strong,
okay,
that's fine.
But then we have all single bonds,
but small rings strain because you don't have such good overlap.
We talked about that.
Okay,
so,
uh,
six to 27 kilocalories of strain there.
We already understand why that is.
But here's an interesting one.
These ones which are bigger than six,
right?
But bigger than six members in the ring,
but they have strain and that string as a strain is called Trans annular across
the ring.
And you can easily see why it is.
There is a view of a model of Cyclohexane at the top and below is cyclo octane.
Now,
of course you buyer thought it would be strained because you'd have to bend the
bonds out.
Busops he says,
you don't have to bend the bonds out.
All you'd have to do is pepper,
right?
And,
but if you start puckering too much opposite sides,
we'll run into one another and you can really see this.
If you look at space filling models of these here,
the repulsion between those two that are across the ring,
you can see the hydrogens really crunch into one another.
So these intermediate sized rings suffer from Trans annular strain.
So you can see this by comparing heats of formation,
which remember,
how do you,
what experiment do you do to measure heats of formation?
What actually would you do when you went into lab?
You have these substances,
what do you do with them in lab in order to vacation there?
He's a formation.
You burned them,
right?
You measure what you actually measure is the heat of combustion,
But then if you also know,
if somebody out there has for you measure the heat of combustion of and the heat
of combustion of hydrogen,
then you have the numbers that Abel you that enable you to work up your data and
find out what the heat of formation of your substance was.
Right?
So now this,
this book at the end in the appendix three of this book has Everage bond
energies.
And this is what Andrew Wanted,
right?
He wanted to be able to start with the Adams and up all the bonds and get the
energy.
And in fact,
here is a table that purports to do that,
that says that these are energies you can add up to get what the heat of
atomization would be.
Uh,
and you'll notice that it makes a little distinction among carbon carbon bonds
that gives different values for double and triple bonds.
Then for single,
that's certainly sensible and same for nitrogen.
So the question is,
does this work?
Can one sum up bond energies to get useful heats of atomization?
So how well can bond energies predict the heat of atomization?
And where does the heat of atomization come from?
So again,
you're going to do these heats of combustion,
but you're going to need somebody to measure a new value for you,
not just the heat of combustion of graphite and the heat of combustion of
hydrogen gas.
And you'll see what you need here.
Because we're going to now compare not with graphite and hydrogen,
which is something you could have in a bottle.
But we're going to compare with the Adams,
which you can't have in a bottle.
Now,
how are we going to measure the heat of atomization?
We're going to do it indirectly by,
uh,
by this line,
right?
We know the heat of combustion of our substance,
or we measure it,
we know the heat of combustion of graphite and hydrogen.
So all we need to know is the heat of atomization of graphite.
How hard is it to,
to get a carbon atom out of graphite or a hydrogen atom out of h two.
If we knew that,
then we could figure out that that's going to be 650.6 kilocalories per mole.
That's to get out six carbons from graphite and 12 hydrogens from h two gas in
order to make the c six h 12 of Cyclohexane,
right?
So if you knew that number,
the 1650 0.6 the heat of atomization of graphite and hydrogen,
then you can add all those together with the proper sign and get that at 680.1
the heat of atomization of cyclohexane.
And then you could try to parlay that into what the bond strengths are in
cyclohexane.
So what you need is the heat of atomization of graphite and the heat of
atomization of hydrogen.
But how can you know the heat of formation for an Adam?
You do it by spectroscopy.
So we've seen things like this before,
a more type curve,
and we know that you have an x,
y,
a diatomic Adam down in the bottom there.
And if you,
it takes a certain amount of energy to get to x plus y to get to the atoms.
If you knew that energy,
that's what we want to know.
How hard is it to break these apart?
H Two for example,
into two h atoms.
But you notice that you could do this with light and if you knew what the
minimum amount of light is to go up,
of course it's going to be quantized right.
They're going to be given levels until you get to the level where it associates.
And then as you'll remember from from Arabic meets Goldilocks,
it's not quantized anymore.
You can have any energies that you want.
So if by spectroscopy you can see when it's changes from being individual lines
to being a continuum where any energy goes,
then you know what that energy is so you'd know how much energy it takes to go
from the molecule to the addict.
So you could do that by spectroscopy.
And within the case of hydrogen molecule,
it turns out to be 104.2 but from that you get two hydrogen atoms.
So it's 52.1 is the heat of formation from the gas of a hydrogen atom.
So we know that we,
because the heat of formation of h two is defined to zero,
that's the element in its standard state already.
You can do the same thing with oxygen and you get that it's 59.6 to make an
oxygen.
But how do you do carbon?
Because the standard state of carbon is not c two
right?
And and indeed you can't buy c two in a bottle to do the experiment either.
But what you can get in a bottle is CEO carbon monoxide.
So if you did the experiment on CEO,
you find out that that number is 257.3 and now you have what you need because
that's the difference between CEO and a Seattle plus an oh Adam.
But you know where CEO is compared to graphite and oxygen by burning CEO and you
know where oxygen is relative to oxygen and its standard state.
Because we just did it with o two,
right?
So there's burning graphite is 26.4 uh,
got graph graphite to a single oxygen atom.
Is,
is that heat of formation of the oxygen out.
And so all we need to have to have is that difference.
And we know what the heat of formation of carbon is.
It's going to be 171.3 okay.
So we were able to do it by doing spectroscopy on CEO,
but this was done.
People got the number 171.3 but then they began to worry and there were two
Nobel laureates plus Edward Teller who the,
who was big in the atomic energy community in the United States.
You may have heard of him,
uh,
who,
so we're big time physicists who absolutely disagreed with 171.3 because what
they said was that the was misleading that actually it was giving one of the,
this,
the light that was going in was giving one of the Attos,
not in its normal state,
it's low energy state,
but in the higher state.
So the number that you predicted that,
that you measured is 171.3 was not to a normal carbon atom,
but to an excited carbon atom.
Right?
So that the true energy of a carbon atom would be lower than that.
And so they thought one set up and thought it would be 141 kilocalories per
mole.
And another thought it would be a 125 so these numbers are all very precise.
You can measure these positions of spectral lines very accurately,
but you don't know how to interpret it.
It could be way off by 20 or 20 or almost 50 kilocalories per mole.
So you need some other way of doing this.
And for many years,
I brought in a guest lecturer to explain how he did it,
but unfortunately,
he died a year and a half ago.
So,
uh,
I'll have to tell you what he would have told you and I,
but we'll wait next time for that.